the grammy nominations were announced
yesterday and the big snub that
everybody's talking about is of course
the weekend
he was expected to be a front-runner in
record album and song of the year
he ended up with zero nominations
at all wasn't even nominated in the pop
categories after the snub the weekend
tweeted
the grammys remain corrupt you owe me my
fans and the industry transparency
now the grammys actually responded to
the weekend so the interim president
says
i was surprised and can empathize with
what he's feeling
his music this year was excellent and
his contributions to the music community
and broader world are worthy of
everyone's admiration
we were thrilled when we found out he
would be performing at the upcoming
super bowl
and we would have loved to have him also
perform on the grammy stage the weekend
before
unfortunately every year there are fewer
nominations than the number
of deserving artists but as the only
pure voted music award we will continue
to recognize and celebrate excellence in
music
while shining a light on the many
amazing artists that make up our global
community
yeah now there's been some speculation
that he was snubbed because he was
announced as a super bowl halftime
performer
which would have made it unlikely that
it would have been able to perform the
week before
on the grammys but the recording academy
shoots that rumor down saying this to be
clear
voting in all categories ended well
before the weekend's performance
at the super bowl was announced so in no
way
could have affected the nomination
process now the weekend's last two
albums won the urban contemporary album
category
so that category has been renamed best
progressive r b
album he submitted his album there but
the r b grammy committee decided to move
to the much more competitive pop vocal
album category he submitted heartless
for the r
b categories blinding lights in your
eyes and over now in pop
yeah he failed to get enough votes in
any category to get a knock
yeah now someone who was nominated the
pop category was justin bieber and
bieber's changes album
was nominated for best pop vocal album
yummy was nominated for best
pop vocal performance and he was
nominated for intentions alongside cuevo
for best pop duo or group performance
but bieber is not
happy he's nominated in the pop category
he wrote on instagram
changes was and is an r b album it is
not being acknowledged as an r b
album which is very strange to me for
this not to be put into that category
feels weird considering
from the chords to the melodies to the
vocal style all the way down to the
hip-hop drums that were chosen
it is undeniably and unmistakably an r b
album yes nancy says he was robbed yes
he says blinding lights is a huge song
what more does it take um nelson says i
don't know anything about it but i guess
others were better
janiece says taylor's new album is not
pop it's not a pop album as well yeah
that's interesting she could have
submitted that
folk or americana album but yeah so a
lot of it comes down to
where the artist and the label actually
submits right their music a lot of time
it's not that grammy's deciding where an
album is going to go but
no they can't move stuff too yeah and i
think that they have the same problem
right i think that bieber and and the
weeknd are dealing with the same sort of
situation
i don't know where they submitted
justin's album that's the sort of
question mark but everything else was
submitted for pogba all the yummies
yeah yummy intentions and the other were
all submitted in
pop the pop vocals like solo categories
but yeah we don't know about the album
for sure but it would make sense
yeah it does so so to me bieber's
problem is with his own organization
rather than the grammys and that's a
that's something that he should probably
talk about privately because if that's
the case
he's you know i'm not saying he's gonna
have to apologize but you know
somebody's gonna have to do some
explaining as far as the weekend goes
having submissions in multiple
categories
sort of puts you in a weird position
where if you don't fall directly
in line in that lane you may lose out on
everything
because you won't have enough votes to
sort of make it to the
album and and everything and everything
else um and
you know is the weekend a pop act or is
the weekend an r b
act that's the i don't know
i don't know and if you're an r b voter
and you hear blinding lights or the rest
of that album
are you are you saying this is r b or
you're saying this is pop and if you're
pop
knowing the history of the weekend at
the grammys are you saying no this is a
sort of pop-leaning r b album and then
you're like this doesn't belong in this
category either
so it's it's tough but i i i
it's unfortunate that it seems like in
order to get nominated
you really have to stick in your lane
right and i don't know if the grammys
will ever look at bieber as an r b
artist
bieber may release an r b album but he
is 100 a pop artist yeah
because there absolutely is a thing it
is changing but there was the idea that
if you're a black guy or she nominated r
b if you're a white artist you get
nominated a pop and that seems to be a
little bit of the case they didn't
nominate the weekend
in pop they didn't nominate bieber in r
b yeah from all indications it seems
like bieber was submitted in the pop so
his problem is with the label yeah the
weekend's an interesting one because the
other thing i wonder too so they're
i'm still not fully understanding what
the process is but the r b committee
listened to his album decided no this is
an r b enough needs to go to pop right
is there communication that happens that
says hey guys
we're not considering the weekend you
know r b
so now it's on you guys and pop to
nominate the weekend is there that
conversation like is this like instance
where
they moved in the pop a lot of the pop
voters didn't even realize that the
weekend
was now exclusively in pop like i don't
know what the communication
that happens there because i mean these
are huge committees right and they're
listening to all this different music so
you wonder if he just kind of
slipped through the cracks that they
didn't realize they had moved him to pop
i don't know what the circumstance is
well and yeah i don't i don't know yeah
i don't know i
and it's it's messy and you know the
weekend is calling for
transparency which you know is i think
that the most you could ask for he's not
raging he's not coming out saying i was
better than everybody
all he was asking for was transparency
because it is peculiar it's peculiar
that nothing was nominated that's what
seems really weird is that
there wasn't one category
right that somebody decided to recognize
everything he's done off that record
i mean yazzy points to another thing
bieber should just be nominated he was
uh should be just be happy he was
nominated his latest music is not good
yeah that changes album was not very
good no and it disappeared real fast
like even think bieber fans would admit
that was not his strongest
works i don't know how yummy got a best
pop solo
performance nomination intentions is a
great song that was the only thing good
about that album
i have no idea how that album got
nominated for best pots alone